this morning 8-2-6 an Innovative writing program
co-founded by one of the nation's most celebrated
authors molding the next generation of
storytellers 826 Valencia was formed in
San Francisco by Dave Eggers and Nineveh Caligari
it's now expanded into nine chapters around the
country serving more than 350 000 students each
year the program focuses on making sure as many
students as possible get one-on-one attention and
that they see their names and stories in Prince
and have some fun along the way walk into 826
Valencia Street in San Francisco and you'll find
what's believed to be the only store in the world
entirely dedicated to selling pirate supplies but
get beyond that and you soon realize the point
of this place is not to Hawk fake gold coins
it is to deliver very real dreams I wanted
the place to be weird we wanted it to be kind
of homey and strange and totally unexpected
and have a sense of humor because kids are
so funny they're so strange and funny and we so
rarely Embrace that and reflect it back to them
a pirate's life for me the weird storefronts have
become a staple at 826 writing centers around the
world from secret agents in Chicago okay are you
guys ready to go through the secret passageway to
superheroes in Brooklyn a time travel mart in Los
Angeles and a woodland creature Outfitter store
at their newest location in San Francisco when
you create a place that is profoundly beautiful
and wonderful and surprising and young people
walk through that space it's a transformative
experience for them and it sends them the message
something's going to be different here over the
past 20 years 826 has become the largest youth
Writing Center in the world if you could talk to
your ancestor what would you ask them matching
up volunteer tutors ask them what were they
eating at the old times oh really with students
in under-resourced communities all free of charge
founded by Dave Eggers and Nineveh kalagare the
current director is beaten azerian a former School
principal I think that's what 826 does so well is
it says students voices matter here's the support
you need as a teacher as a young person
in our system and then let's publish you
Edgar's first major success in the publishing
world was the Memoir a heartbreaking Work of
Staggering Genius the book turned him into a
literary Superstar and he soon discovered he
knew lots of others who were looking for
ways to contribute to their communities
kaligari was a teacher working in a school
overwhelmed with too many students I had
146 students and any one given time I never had
enough time to give them the attention I thought
they deserved and I just knew that teachers out
there would be super thirsty for this service
and and that was true Jimmy and Latifah were
two of the students there when we visited High
person reading this I'll be telling you in my
own words how I see the future they shared some
of their own published works on a lonely land I
care for my grandma says Mom Grandpa and myself
because they're my family do you think it's cool
to see your name in print yes I mean you get it
it's a nice feeling it's kind of reflects it's a
flex yeah it very much is a flex yeah there's a
confidence and a calm that comes over a published
Young author because they feel like I got it right
I put it on paper it's in this book that's my
truth it's there permanently Osvaldo Marquez Gomez
is a former student he's been published 11 times
what did 826 do that the schools couldn't it was
that one-on-one intention I had a hard time asking
for help so once a tutor is visual like visually
sitting there and like what's going on like what
are you processing what questions do you have so
like that proactive like one-on-one attention is I
feel like that goes a long way it's pretty wild to
think like you see the student 15 20 years ago
and then he's my boss now yeah he's your boss
yeah on the board sits on the board of directors
Oswaldo now helps oversee a writing program at a
time when there were 2500 documented cases of
books being banned last year an all-time high
gers recently joined that list he was really
surprised I had to that my book The Circle was
banned in a school district in Rapid City South
Dakota I had to look back at the book to figure
out what there was and that I don't remember
anything and it would have been objectionable
but I was there a couple weeks ago and talking
to teachers and talking to students and we had
amazing sessions and the teachers are incredibly
resilient they're finding ways around it
is not meant to replace the education system
but supplement it in ways most schools can't
and it's about the people who are willing to
give their time to help these kids find a voice
and in the process maybe ReDiscover their
own [Music] what the 826 tutors taught me
and what Dave has brought to the world is this
huge reminder that learning is also joyful and
I think that public school teachers are doing
their best in in difficult circumstances and I
do think when there's so much stress and strain
on that system that it is it is difficult to
remember that that learning can be joyful and
that it can be driven by love and kindness
um what a great reminder I would try to find
despite all the stresses and everything else
and joy yeah in these places and just
no matter what these these people have
accomplished here Dave you know whatever
it's only important if they can give back
and instead of taking that and giving
it back and passing it on to the next
Generation that's a wonderful thing it
is and so is this it's a shipwreck that
was underwater for more than 500 years so it's
taken kind of time to dry out two decades after
its Discovery this remarkable wreck is ready for
its close-up that's next on CBS Saturday morning
foreign [Music]
welcome back and what is really cool Jeff about
this I love the storefronts and all of it because
I'm looking behind you so it's gorgeous that
alone this is a sparkling creature Outfitters
I mean but that alone Sparks so much creativity
yeah child and anyone really so my question is
how do kids sign up for this or is it you
know it's they have limited resources for
this in terms of availability so how do we
how big if parents are interested for their
kids you go to the website a26's website
and check it out see if it's in the area
you know they're not in every city in the
country um but they are international now
as well there are international locations but
I asked them I said what you know what's your
goal for the next 20 in 20 years from now so 40
years in they said we would love to be able to
provide services to every single under-resourced
child in this country that is wonderful which it
is wonderful and it's I mean it's it's a massive
goal yeah it's also ambitious and it is you know
know with Public Schools it is a huge problem
across the country if you talk to anybody who
public schools that are in well-taxed areas
versus not well even in well-taxed areas the
numbers are high of classroom size but at least
the funding is there yeah in those other areas
it's it's awful what we see though is that these
programs work right they make a difference and
these kids can provide them and Thrive and don't
we want our children to do that you open them up